socorridos al borde de la extenuación
así fueron rescatados cientos de
migrantes de las aguas del mediterráneo
tras una última operación que duró más
de cinco horas de trabajo
el buque humanitario conocido como ocean
by king rescató a 369 emigrantes que se
encontraban frente a las costas de libia
ya son 572 migrantes incluidos 183
menores los que han sido rescatados en
poco más de tres días desde que el buque
comenzó la misión también en las costas
de malta el último rescate ha ido bien
la gente se encuentra a salvo en el
lausanne biking pero está en física y
sicológicamente muy afectados y muchos
incluso tuvieron que ser evacuados en
camilla porque no podían caminar tras
unos días de ardua tarea el grupo
humanitario también se quejó de que las
autoridades marítimas no habían ayudado
en las operaciones y llamó a la unión
europea a intervenir hacemos un llamado
a la unión europea para que al menos
coordine ahora el desembarco de los 572
supervivientes actualmente a bordo de
nuestro barco en un puerto seguro
las operaciones de rescate del barco
realizadas incluso en la oscuridad de la
noche dejan ver un final en el que los
botes de madera vacíos son incendiados
por los mismos rescatistas un
procedimiento habitual para evitar
colisiones accidentales en el margen de
lausanne biking es uno de los pocos
barcos de rescate civil activos en el
mediterráneo central desde que sus
operaciones iniciarán en 2019 ha
rescatado a cientos de miles de personas
que se lanzan a la dura travesía en el
mar al menos unos 866 migrantes según la
organización internacional para las
migraciones han perdido la vida en su
intento de llegar a europa con el deseo
de unas condiciones de vida más dignas